so last night something went down I'm
gonna tell the story here but all week
last week my opener was telling me about
this new outfit he bought he finally got
a new outfit because he never it wears
good clothes and he was talking about
how on Friday I'm that when we did the
show we were gonna do the show together
and how he was gonna kill it and I was
gonna be the star because he's got this
new outfit and finally people are gonna
be paying attention to him and not me
even though he's opening for me and so
he's got this new outfit from G star and
he was so excited and he kept showing us
the picture and the group text of the of
the outfit and about how cool it was and
I was like we ain't he's like you guys
aren't [ __ ] when I put this outfit on so
I went the day before the show and I
bought the same outfit and I wore it as
well to [ __ ] his whole night up this is
the outfit anyway I don't even like it
it's a [ __ ] it's a specific thing
it's not like just a black t-shirt and
[ __ ] you know so it's it's they've got
the logo and then the motocross knees
which is looks like you're trying too
hard but you got to do it you got to
ruin your friend's night sometimes if
you don't ruin your friend's nights
honestly you're you ain't [ __ ] right you
ain't [ __ ] if you don't do that and he's
got the bees like I got black Jordans he
didn't have the good ones I'm gonna get
you know I got a lot of shoes and [ __ ]
I'm gonna pick the [ __ ] the better
version of the [ __ ] Jordans that he
has and wear them so he I'm doing his
outfit right
dude you ain't [ __ ] I'm dressed like you
[Music]
[ __ ] killed okay it's when it's when
the student takes over for the daddy
dude you don't dress like patty you
don't dress like the [ __ ] hand that
feeds you okay
telemetric look out pina
[Applause]